في حديث الصباح وحديثنا هذا الصباح واليوم
يا عادل مع النساء ولدعم النساء فلا حياه
من دون نساء طبعا مزبوط يا عادل ولا عمل
ايضا من دونهن لكن رغم تفوق الكثير من
النساء مهنيا الا انهن بحاجه لاجتياز
العديد من العقبات تخيل عدد هذه العقبات
طبعا وتخيلي ايضا يا راويه هذه العقبه
تبلغ 30 عقبه وفق تقرير نشره موقع
هذا الموقع نشر 30
طبعا سنتحدث عن البعض منها ونوجز يعني
الحديث عن البعض الاخر لانه من هذه
العقبات التحيز والتمييز الجنسي ايضا
عقبات اخرى كثيره كانت السبب في اعاقه
النساء في سوق العمل لسنوات طويله طيب
القصه الموجزه التي توصل اليها البحث هي
ان النساء مهما فعلت لا يكفي فاذا كانت
صغيره يقال انها اصغر من ان تشغل مركزا
قياديا واذا كانت كبيره يقال انها خلاص
كبرت سعل هذا الرجال ولكن
المشاهدين مهمه جدا هي الامومه فالام
العامله يعتبر رؤساؤها في العمل انها
مشغوله دائما مع ابنائها ولا تستطيع
الانجاز اما التي لدي ليس لديها اطفال
ايضا يطلب منها العمل
بجديه اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تنضم الينا الخبيره في الموارد البشريه
ميدا غازي اهلا بك وصباح الخير صباح الخير
عقبه تواجه المراه براويه قالت ايضا
والرجل مو عاجبه الان اقول للرجل مسكين
عنده عقبه واحده وهي الامراه بس انا اول
مره
خلينا نتكلم اليوم بانه اليوم هل بالفعل
ما زلنا يعني في ظل تمكين المراه من تبوء
مناصب قياديه ما زلنا نعاني من هذا
التمييز والفوارق بين الجنسين في العمل
هلا نحن عم نعاني من هذا الموضوع فعلا بس
بطل الموضوع مثل قبل
فيني اقول انه نحنا على الخط الصحيح
لتبواؤ الامراه مراكز قياديه يعني اذا
بدنا نحكي باميركا في فورتش
صار كان من قبل ثمانيه بالميه من النساء
يتبواؤون السي اي او او المراكز
او علقان لفتره معينه هلا من جديد وصلنا
لعشره بالميه فنحن هلا بنقول انه مع تغير
الظروف مع حتى الشركات عم تفرض صارت نسبه
مئويه
للنساء في مراكز قياديه هذا الشيء عم
بيساعد كثير كمان في عنا نتائج عم بتفرجي
انه قديه النساء قادرات على انه
يحققوا نجاح ويحققوا ارباح بالشركات ورفع
الانتاجيه للموظفين كرمال هيك نحن بنقول
انه اكيد ما وصلنا مطرح ما لازم النساء
يكونوا موجودين بالنسبه لقدراتهم
ومهاراتهم بس نحن على الخط الصحيح على
الدراسه بتتحدث عن 30 عقبات طبعا هي سمتهم
اذا بتسمحولي فقط هيك بس يعني امشي بشكل
سريع على بعض منهم منها اللون
الوزن ايضا العمر حكينا عن العمر حكينا
ايضا عن الامومه بانها يعني بعض النقاط
التي يميز ضد النساء بسببها لكن ايضا في
عنا الاثنيه في عنا الخلفيه الثقافيه في
عنا كمان موضوع الجنسيه
وضعها اذا كانت متزوجه ام غير متزوجه
قدرتها الجسديه شكلها سعيدا بحس انه كثير
من هاي النقاط ما عدا الامومه والعمر يمكن
تنطبق على الرجال ايضا هي كلها ايضا عقبات
ممكن لاي رجل انه يواجهها في نطاق العمل
صحيح هل هذا صحيح مزبوط لانه اليوم اذا
انا بدي اعمل مع اي شخص متقدم للعمل اول
شيء اول ما يفوت الشخص عم تطلعي انت على
الايموج هل هذا الشخص بيظبط مع ثقافه
الشركه مع الوضع العام للشركه هاو ايفر
هذا الشيء ما بيخليك تاخذي قرار بتوظيف او
عد هذا الشخص ان كان امراه او رجل نحن
اليوم بنقعد مع شخص نشوف مهاراته التقنيه
منشوف السوفت سكيل تبعه مهاراته من
الناحيه النظريه ولكن هل هذا يطبق عمليا
عند التوظيف فعليا ولا الناس مثلا قلبها
او مش قلبها ولكن يعني في شخصين بنفس
المؤهلات ونفس الخبره ولكن حبوا شخص اكثر
من الاخر لاي سبب من الاسفلوا احلى بيلبس
احسن بيتحدث افضل في شيء كتير مهم اسمه
قبول الوجه للشخص اللي عم بيعمل الانترفيو
في عالم بتحسي انه عندهم نفس المهارات بس
بنفس الوقت في شخص مقبول اكثر او يمكن
المحادثه عنده اهم او يمكن بيقدر يوصل
فكرته او يقدر اكسبريس يعبر عن نفسه اكثر
بس بشكل عام نحن لا دائما بنطلع على
المقدم على طلب التوظيف على قديه بيقدر
يعطي قيمه للشغل يلي بده يعطيه بس موجود
موضوع الشكل بكثير شركات بعض الموجود يعني
مع الرجال ربما في المقابله يفضل هذا على
ذاك هذا امر اخر لكن خلينا نتكلم بانه
البعض يقول ماذا تريد النساء يعني اليوم
تريد كل المراكز القياديه ان يكونون نساء
طب ما هم ماخذين الرجل حتى يرى ان هناك
تمييز ضده اذا كانت المراه غير متزوجه
ويطلب منها العمل ربما البعض منهن يلجانا
الى انه والله انا امراه ما قدرت اتاخر
الى هذا الوقت فلماذا تستخدم البعض هذه
ربما الحيال انجاز التعبير هي الهروب من
العمل ليه عم بتسميها من العمل انا يعني
بكل شيء اكيد بس الامراه الناجحه والطموحه
ما بتحط حيل بالعكس بتلاقي الوقت المناسب
وبتلاقي الظروف المناسبه لتعمل عملها على
اكمل وجه كمان اليوم نحن ما بدنا نطلب
هي واصله على مراكز كثيره مهمه وهي ام وهي
زوجه وهي اخت وهي
بس هو شو عم يعمل بالبيت اليوم اذا هو
زوجه
المدرسه يلي عم تيجي مثلا
حتى بعض الرجال في مجتمعاتنا العربيه يقول
للمراه من عتبه البيت والخارج هذه
مسؤوليتي عتبه البيت والداخل هذه مسؤوليتك
يتقاسمون بس اليوم ما فينا نقول الامراه
هي شو بدها اليوم انا اذا بدي اقول امراه
ناجحه بشغل هذه الامراه ما حتعمل حيل
بالشغل وتقول انا بدي روح كرمال ابني وانا
بدي خلينا خلينا نقول قبل ما ننهي بانه
رغم كل العقبات النساء عندها قدره هائله
على الاصرار وعلى المضي قدما وراح نكمل
طبعا
الحياه لا تستمر الا فيهم صحيح
الموارد البشريه اخاف منهم
شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات